Я пережила вже два Голодомори і дві війни пережила.
Дуже вимерло багато людей, бо тоді ж у 1933 році дуже сильний був голод.
Хто їх там ховав? Їх кидали, я вам кажу як, скидали, як дрова.
Та й усе, засипали землею.
Нічого не було! Що вдома зготуєш? Нічого!
Ні собаки не було, ні кота не було, людей їли.
Це ж все страхіття Боже.
Ви не повірите, думаєте, що це неправда.
Я не знаю, як я вижила. Я якась безсмертна.
Я Ганна Василівна. Я пережила вже два Голодомори і дві війни пережила.
У діда було 4 сини і 4 дочки, восьмеро було дітей.
Моєму батькові дід поставив хатину, дав трошки землі.
Ми перебралися в ту хатину, батько й мати, а нас вже було двоє.
Братик у мене був 2 роки, мені 5.
І ми там посиділи, може, з пів року - все, почали шукати куркулів.
Хто багатий, хто багатше живе, хто бідний, стали так шукати.
Знайшли пів села. Давай всіх виселяти.
Діда і бабу - під'їхала хура, і ще  була дочка в них менша, 15 років.
І цю дочку посадили, отак вийшли з хати і поїхали.
Батька забрали, на північ затаскали.
Я навіть знаю адресу, бо батько писав потім до мене:
Мурманська залізна дорога, станція Медгора, пошта Даніловка.
Каже, привезли їх туди, привезли їх у байрак.
Назгонили їх багато, велика будівля, і туди їх привезли на цей Сибір.
Каже, ні світла, нічого…
Як оце батька з цих покоїв повезли і дядька, то треба і сім'ю туди ж.
Наказали, що готуйтеся, під'їде хура.
Як вони прийшли - мати лежить при смерті.
То один каже: "Це вона так придурюється, нічого вона не слаба".
Привели лікаря до цієї матері, лікар подивився на неї та й махнув рукою.
Та й вони пішли, покинули нас там коло тітки.
Мати померла коло цієї тітки, цей мій братик помер, а я одна залишилася.
Братик з голоду.
Де ж ця тітка, що вона сама одна може?
А мати померла через те, що батька стерегла, та й там заслабла.
Вона ж після пологів.
І я вже була коло цієї тітки.
У неї теж ноги попухли, але в неї дітей не було, то вона прихистила нас.
Дуже багато цих сиріт залишилося.
Дуже людей сильно багато вимерло, бо дуже сильний голод був.
То беруть в патронат, зробили такий патронат.
А нас не приймають у патронат, бо ми куркульські.
Якісь начальники там були партійні, комсомольці чи там хто.
У хату приходять, забирають, де що є, геть все забирають.
І в колгосп, і в колгосп, і в колгосп…
Третя частина села.
Котрі люди робили, вміли господарювати, не лежні були, трошки краще жили,
та й вони їх замели, замели, замели.
Вислати, вислати, вислати, і все…
Дуже вимерло багато людей, бо тоді ж у 1933 році дуже сильний був голод.
У 1933-му варили хамулу.
Зробили котли ці, варили там.
Привезе тітка цієї муки трошки, так задурить цю водичку, то й так вже пили цю воду.
Бо ж на роботу треба йти, треба щось їсти. Та й таке.
Нічого не було! Що вдома зготуєш? Нічого.
А боже… Ми, котрі менші, коло цих покоїв, де пани повтікали,
вони насіяли такого салату, щавлик такий, то ми туди "пастися" ходили.
Старі ходили, і всякі ходили.
Потім вже стало літо, то акація цвіте, все цвіте.
Та й ми цим живилися, жили.
А як стали молотити вже в колгоспі, стала машина молотити,
то віють віялки, обвіває лобода, дуже бур'яни були великі,
не було ж ні міндоброва, нічого.
То ми побіжимо, нахапаємо цієї лободи, а вона…
Як наваримо цієї каші, а вона хрустить так, і ми їмо її.
Всі люди валялися: те лежить там, те сидить там неживе, те сидить там.
Бог його знає, скільки я їла.
Або раз їла, або й не їла. Де що будеш їсти?
А нема нічого, дівчата, гірше, ніж коли їсти хочеться.
Все одно людина, що звірина.
Нічого не миле, нічого не бачиш і нічого не чуєш - аби їсти що.
Ноги пухли і все.
Тоді майже всі вимерли.
Стільки народу вимерло та й все.
Мало що залишилося.
Ця тітка піде в Чорну чи в Москалівку, пішла, виміняла якось пшона на суп.
Ну то дорогою вилазять, переймають і обдирають.
Тітка взяла, закрутила тут у коси.
Прийшла тітка та й плаче, і розказує:
"Перейняли, поклали, з кіс видерли це пшоно".
А занесеш хустинку якусь, то дасть або дві картоплі, або кусочок хліба.
Та й вимерли люди геть. Таке життя було.
Не можна в магазині нічого було купити.
Один тільки магазин десь там в якомусь місті називався "Торгсин".
То в кого було золото, то той піде, купить хліба.
А в кого немає, гроші є -  не купиш ніде, нічого немає.
Приходить бурса і все, забирають, де що є.
Якісь плужки були, земля була, теж щось робили там.
А ці вже плачуть, виск вже такий на селі, що забирають усе в них.
Що в кого, яка корівка, яке що.
Все забирають, все забрали в колгосп!
А їсти нема нічого, нічого!
Ні собаки не було, ні кота не було, людей їли…
Ну, я ж вам кажу, що нема нічого, як людина голодна, все одно, що звір.
І все, таке було.
Хто їх там ховав? Їх кидали, я вам кажу як, скидали, як дрова.
Та й все, засипали землею.
Я не знаю, як я вижила. Я якась безсмертна.
Як повимирали ці люди, порожні хати, де яка баба залишилася, то ж пусті хати.
Завозять, збивають коробку таку, ніби ліжко.
І завозять у цю хату, туди наносять гною.
І ми місимо руками в цій коробці гній та й робимо гранулі такі.
Отак качаємо, ніби яблука, ось таке качаємо.
Як уже навесні садити – викопали ямку,
гранулю туди і картоплину, гранулю і картоплину.
А хто ж ту картоплину кине? То зрізують зрізочки.
За зиму назрізують зрізочки, оббирають картоплю,
теж лушпайок ніде не дівають.
Лушпайки ці, зрізочки, і цю гранулю сюди.
І що думаєте? І посходить, і така гарна картопля.
Це ж все страхіття Боже. Ви не повірите. Думаєте, що це неправда?
Це все істинна правда! Це все на моїй душі.
Зараз Міша каже: "Ти не думай нічого".
Як я не буду, як я лежу, не можу спати?
І воно мені все на думці, мені зараз йде в голову, стаю слаба.
Ось цілий день не їси, то ввечері як йти спати?
Йдеш, гризеш, що бачиш.
Дерево яке, де листя, де що є їси та й все.
Потім вже війна почалася.
Боже... Пройшло кілька днів - вже німці в Северинах.
Німці зайшли, бачимо, Боже!
Такі машини повне село, називалися "Катюші" і "Ванюші" ці машини.
І такі з хрестами.
А ця тітка каже: "Ой, це, напевно, вони дуже у Бога вірують,
бо дуже машини з хрестами". Ага..
Прийшли ми додому, цілу ніч крик, чоловіків до одного забрали.
Забирають, все везуть і везуть.
Ті, що в армії були, жоден не повернувся.
Вони ж усі там полягли. Всі полягли.
Та й таке…
Як вже почалася ця війна, то нас евакуювали.
Із Северин евакуювали в Остропіль. Повиганяли.
Просто хто не хотів евакуюватися – вбивали німці, вбивали.
Вигляне отак хто-небудь - вбило і все.
Стали брати вже молодь у Німеччину.
Беруть по роках.
Оце прийде на пошту: стільки-то з села треба, 20 душ чи 50 душ.
Все, перший рік, потім другий з років.
А мій рік вже був останній, бо я була менша, то 1927-й рік вже був останній.
То декого забрали, а я не була.
Ми ховалися по тих порожніх хатах, де позалишалися, на горах.
А потім вже стало доходити, що там на горах ті діти ховаються.
То ми в Бражинці, Житенці, на селах вже були.
То я не була в Німеччині. Нас багато не було.
Щось мало було з 1927-го року в Німеччині.
Хоч вони німці, але так не робили.
Такого не було страховіття, як ось зараз.
Якось давали трохи, якось виписували, якось по-іншому було.
Якось ми повиживали. А зараз що?
Але пішли всі, цей народ пішов, тоді мало що залишилося.
А це найшло знову якесь...
Хто його знає, чи воно від Бога, чи від сатани...
То вже робіть щось, кажу, з тим Путіним,
або десь його подіньте вже, щоб він там здох вже десь.
Нічого. Україна переможе їх.
Україна не дасться.
Зараз українці розумні, вони б'ють і все.